Please welcome Eric Kim.
(crowd clapping)
(crowd cheering)
Thank you, thank you.
How does it feel when you get to drop the mic
and be like, "Yeah, I work for the 'New York times'."
(laughs) It feels, I don't know, that's my job.
It's like my day job that I love,
but this all is just so new for me.
It's my first book so this all feels very surreal.
Take us through the dish we are making,
teach us, teach us, teach us.
Yes. Okay.
So this dish is very exciting near and dear to my heart.
It is at the end of this section called TV Dinners.
And so here are right now we have this kalbi going.
kalbi is a short rib that's been cut a certain way
and it's a really convenient cut
'cause it cooks pretty quickly.
We're just frying it with salt and pepper.
You know, I've tested this multiple ways
but the simplest is often the best.
So it's quite easy.
We just need to flip it now I think,
ooh see.
Oh my God.
That's great.
Look at that sear.
Yeah, yours looks great.
Oh God, it smells so good you guys.
(laughs) So you know this is just going
and what you do is
start the potato a salad while that's going.
I love potato salad so much.
So we should get Jimmy out here again
'cause there's mayonnaise.
Oh!
(Eric laughs)
I mean he really-
No goat cheese though-
It is his kryptonite.
Yeah.
So actually what I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna
mash this up, this potato salad is like amped up.
It's just so delicious
and something that you can bring to a picnic.
I like having it a little warm
and that's the pleasure of making this at home
'cause this is actually we're gonna see,
it looks like the Korean restaurant kind.
We're gonna have it like as a scoop.
And so we're just adding some cucumbers.
You don't want that (indistinct).
I'm just getting rid
of my excess water.
Nice, yes.
You don't want the excess water.
So these cucumbers have been drained with like a little salt
and it's kind of part of my mom was like,
"You need to make sure
that there's no water in the cucumbers."
And I thought that was genius
'cause it makes the it makes the mashed potatoes
last longer in the fridge.
Oh.
Yeah.
If there's less water.
So, and then these vegetables,
does everyone recognize these?
Oh, a frozen medley.
Yes.
Never seen them before.
They came from my garden but it has to be this mix.
It has to be.
I love the word medley.
(laughs) Yeah.
So this mayonnaise has vinegar and sugar.
The sugar balances, it don't be afraid.
There's a little salt as well
if you wanna season it later,
but you know you add as much
or as little as you want honestly.
And I'll probably do a little salt 'cause salt's good.
Salt brings out everything, you know?
And when you mix it up
you'll see it's this really beautiful...
It looks confetti-ed, I call it confetti-ed
(crowd clapping)
(laughs) mash potatoes.
So this is called gamja salad.
Gamja?
Yes, gamja means potato and we know salad.
Yeah, tell me about the barbecue sauce.
Okay, so yum that tastes good.
You can have a tastes
if you wanna like see how it's balanced,
you wanna like add salt, you wanna add pepper if you want.
It's all about what you like.
Whoa! Ooh whoa!
It's good right? It's very simple.
Oh my God I was not expecting that.
(laughs) I love that.
There's a little bit of acid.
There's a little acid, yeah, it's important.
But then with the mayonnaise it's also the sugar
that you might be reacting to.
Wow.
Balances everything else.
I'm all about balance, and that reaction, thank you.
I like surprising people when they take a bite.
They're like, "Oh, I wasn't expecting that."
And the pea and the corn pops.
I love it.
Yeah, that's great.
It's really comforting, I think that-
What's in the barbecue sauce?
So this is the glaze
(crowd clapping)
that we're using to lacker these ribs
that we've cooked up and it's really just like ketchup,
brown sugar or Worcestershire sauce, garlic.
It's like all these really delicious ingredients.
I really think that these flavors,
what I loved about this book and this recipe specifically
is it tells a story of my cooking
that I remember growing up with, but also my mom's past.
And so this is sort of a love letter to my mom
and it's gonna make me cry
'cause I just like can't do this press story
without like talking about my mom and crying.
But you know, she remembers eating this at restaurants
in Seoul when she was like a 19 year old.
And I remember eating it as a 19 year old
on like my couch in Georgia.
So this book was an opportunity to like talk to her
and kind of interview her
and get to know her story and find those resonances
where we both kind of meet in the middle.
And it's about bringing the past into your present.
And that's kind of the spiel that I have about the thesis
of this book which is write down your family recipes
but also also innovate a little and have fun.
I think it speaks to also what Jimmy
was here to talk about is these books
that really celebrate your families.
If you're so lucky to have them or the found families
that you create and bringing children into knowing
that it's not to be taken for granted
and we have to keep those memories alive.
So I think this is a perfect show to honor your book
and your family.
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)